in this video i'm going to show you how
to program one remote head key
for all a toyota
and scion vehicles that are using this
exact remote head key
for this video i'm sitting inside the
2016 toyota camry
but whether you are sitting in exactly
the same car as i am or any other toyota
vehicle
as long as you are using this exact
remote head key the programming process
is exactly the same
okay a few things that is important for
me to mention before we start is first
of all
once i'm going to program this key
all of the old keys that used to be
working before in the vehicle will be
erase
and this remote head key going to be the
only key that will be programmed and
will stay programmed to the vehicle
after the programming process will be
completed
second of all i'm going to show you now
that this
a key is not yet programmed i'm going to
press the lock
and unlock
okay lock and unlock and you can see
that the remote part of the key is not
programmed and if i'm going to put the
key inside the ignition and i'm going to
try to start the engine
okay you can see and also here that the
key is not starting the engine another
way that you can see that the key is not
programmed is based on this security
light you see that right now the
security light is blinking
if i'm going to put the key the
unprogrammed key inside the ignition the
security light will keep blinking it
will keep blinking because it's not
recognized the key as a programmed key
if the key was a programmed key
once i'm gonna once i would put it
inside the ignition the security light
would disappear because it would
recognize this key as a programmed key
so this is just another way to to to see
that this key is not yet programmed
okay so in this video i'm going to show
you how to program
the remote head key and i'm going to
show you how to do it step by step
okay so what we need to do we need first
of all before everything
to open the driver's side door okay
from now until the end of the
programming process the driver's side
door will have to be open and remain
open the entire process
all of the other doors in the car will
have to be closed and remain closed the
entire of the entire process so again
driver door will have to be open and all
of the other door will have to be closed
and remain closed until you finish the
programming process
all right so next what we need to do
we take the key
put it inside the ignition and we twist
it to the on position
okay next
we take the obd cable adapter
and we need to connect it to the obd
port which is located under the steering
column
okay now we can go to the programming
process and then using the computer hi
i'm ocean i'm sorry to interrupt your
video i know it's a pain in the ass but
look i want to tell you something
important i can tell that you're really
interested in learning about how to
program car keys and remotes well that's
what we do in locksmith videos online so
this youtube channel is just a small
fraction of what we actually do you
should really visit our website at
luxsmithvideosonline.com there you could
find hundreds of videos and tutorials
that will show you step by step how to
program all kind of car keys and remotes
from transponder keys to remote head
keys to smart keys for vehicles that
have a push to start system and much
much more when it comes to the locksmith
field in general and the automotive
field so if you click on the link below
this video or go to
lucksmithvideosonline.com you can have
access to all of the knowledge that i
acquired throughout my 15 years laxmi
career and you can become as
professional as i am on your first day
and on your first try yes i just said it
you can become as professional as i am
on your first day and on your first try
i don't think you can afford to be
without it
[Applause]
[Music]
okay so of course we're going to turn on
the profit right here
okay and after we turn on the profit
we're going to look here
and see that the bluetooth light turned
into blue
it did turn into blue it means that now
we have a connection we can start the
programming process
all right so make sure that your
immobilization at the top
and what we're going to look we're going
to look for us toyota okay there it is
toyota we're going to press on us toyota
in the disclaimer press agree
okay and
we're gonna do this
not always you're gonna have the scream
that i have it so it was just updating
me about something so i just press say
no or okay and right now in this screen
what we're gonna choose we're gonna
choose key
in this screen we're going to choose by
type
in this screen we're going to do we're
going to choose immobilizer
and in this screen we're going to choose
auto identify
the auto identify will try to identify
the
the system the programming system
automatically based on the v number and
as you can see it did find it so we're
going to press ok
[Music]
ok and right now
what we're going to choose we're going
to choose reset immobilizer when all key
is lost so basically we have no key we
want to program one key and we're gonna
choose reset immobilizer all key is lost
now the computer let us know to turn the
ignition to the on position as you can
see the ignition is already in the on
position so you're gonna press ok
now the computer let us know it says
please ensure that the driver door is
open during the process remember i
explained earlier that the driver door
will have to remain open and all of the
other doors in the vehicle will have to
be closed and remain closed so the
computer just let us know that uh to
make sure that we do it okay so we're
gonna press okay
okay uh as you can see procedure
complete turn ignition off remove the
key insert the key and turn the ignition
on okay so basically what we need to do
we need to turn the ignition to the off
position
and take the key out now we need to put
the ignition to the key to the ignition
again into the ignition again and turn
it to the on position
and what we're going to do now we're
going to press ok
now the computer let us know to insert
master key and turn the ignition to the
on position
as you can see the ignition is already
in the on position so we're going to
press ok
communicating
and the computer let us know that the
procedure is complete i want you also to
pay attention here to the security light
the security light and by the way the
security light doesn't have to be here
it can be somewhere else on the
dashboard depending the car that you are
doing but this is how it look it's a car
symbol with a lock inside so you can see
that right now it stays on the moment i
will press ok the security light will
disappear so i'm going to press ok
and as you can see the security light
just disappeared okay so basically right
now the key should be programmed
okay so i will take the key out and the
key part of the remote head key should
be programmed so let's let's test it i'm
going to put the key inside the ignition
twist it to the on position
okay and as you can see and also here
the car started okay that's
because the key is program so now i'm
going to show you that the remote part
of the key is not yet programmed so i'm
going to press the lock
and the unlock
okay you can say that the remote part of
the key is not programmed so basically
this is the remote head key and you have
two parts you have the key with the
transponder chip inside which is already
programmed
but we also have the remote and the
remote part is not yet programmed so now
we're gonna go to the next step which
will be to program the remote okay so
this is how we do it we put the key
inside the ignition and twist it to the
on position
then we're gonna go here to the truck
symbol
the track symbol will take us to the
main screen which we can start the whole
process again
so here we're going to press on us
toyota
in the disclaimer press agree
and
uh uh here we're gonna press yes we're
gonna start new diagnosis if you have
this screen not always you're gonna have
it but if you do press yes
okay in this screen what we're gonna
choose we're gonna choose remote
and here in the screen we're going to
choose auto identify
again the auto identifier will identify
the vehicle based on the v number and
will let us know which system we need to
use and it's going to do it
automatically for us
okay as you can see it did find it as
type 2 and we're going to press ok
ok in this screen what we're going to
choose we're going to choose program
remote
switch ignition on open the driver door
so basically the computer just let us
know that the ignition need to be in the
on position and the driver door needs to
be opened similar to what we did before
all of the doors in the vehicle will
have to remain closed
driver door needs to be open the entire
process until it's going to be done okay
so we're going to press yes
and what we need to do soon and i got
with me another
one second
okay press the lock and unlock together
for 30 seconds and press the lock
the lock button once press ok to
continue so i just got another key in
order to show you what i need to do
because the key inside the ignition is
going to be very hard to see what i'm
going to do we're going to have to press
the lock and unlock together
release it
and then press the lock button and after
that we're gonna hear
something like this so let's do it right
now
press the lock and unlock together for
one second
leave it and then press the lock one
time
okay we didn't hear the the the big beep
but we're gonna press okay let's see if
it catch it
programming success we're gonna press
okay
okay normally after you press the lock
and unlock together
release it and then press the lock you
you you will be able to hear from the
car uh two beeps something like
i didn't hear it maybe it was here but i
didn't hear it maybe it's because i took
a little bit a
longer time than usual because i i was
explaining you what what i'm doing but
basically the computer let us know that
the programming is successful right now
we can put the computer on this side
okay and we can take the key outside of
the ignition and basically right now i
have the key with me and let's test the
remote i'm going to press the lock
and the unlock
okay
lock and unlock and you can see now that
the remote part of the remote head key
is programmed and if i'm going to put
the key inside the ignition
twist it to the on position
okay you can see and also here that the
car started
okay so basically i'm gonna take the key
outside of the ignition
and basically that's it you want to know
how to program car keys and remotes for
all type of vehicles and easily well if
you do then i have the perfect solution
for you hi my name is moshe and i'm the
owner of a locksmith company for over 10
years i'm an expert when it comes to
program car keys and remotes i created a
website full of videos and tutorials
that will guide you step by step how to
program all kind of car keys and remotes
by using this website you will be able
to program all kinds of car keys from
your first day and from your first try
from transponder keys to remote head
keys to smart keys for vehicles that
have a push to start system all you will
have to do is just go to the search bar
and type the make here and model of the
car that you would like to program the
key for then choose the correct video
from the suggested videos and follow the
video step by step it's that easy and if
you would like to order the exact same
key that is being explained in the video
no problem just press on the link at the
bottom of the description and you can
order the exact same key that is being
explained in the video it's that easy go
to
www.luxmitvideosonline.com and see it
for yourself
[Music]
you